la historia de beber viven parece que
tiene de momento un final feliz en torno
a las tres de la tarde se consiguió
reflotarlo por completo y ponerlo rumbo
norte para salir de esa estrecha vía de
agua donde ha estado bloqueando barcos
desde el pasado martes 6 días 400 barcos
portacontenedores se quedaron atrapados
y se han ido acumulando a lo largo de
estos días se espera que en torno a las
ocho de la tarde según dice la autoridad
del canal de suez se restablezca el
tráfico de barcos que le vert viven sin
embargo tendrá que estar esperando la
revisión para ver si su navegabilidad
sigue intacta que se puede poner rumbo a
rotterdam que era el destino al que se
dirigía cuando una tormenta de arena con
fuertes vientos me dejó estancado en el
canal de suez provocando uno de los
mayores atascos marítimos que se
recuerdan en la historia de la
navegación